ich habe mich gerade davon gehört und
scheint mir eine interessante autor zu
sein
er sticht aus der masse der thriller
autoren heraus simon beckett gewinner
des diesjährigen krimi preises
ripplewood seine fünf romane um den
forensischen anthropologen david hunter
sind in fast 30 sprachen übersetzt und
zehn millionen mal verkauft worden
jetzt ist der sechste band erschienen
die ewigen toten in einem längst
verlassenen abbruchreifen spital haben
arbeiter einen grausigen fund gemacht
auf dem dachboden liegt eine tote halb
verwest halb modifiziert
widersprüchliche hinweise
david hunter experte für menschliche
überreste braucht seinen ganzen spürsinn
um herauszufinden wann und woran das
opfer gestorben ist
der mysteriöse fall nimmt horror
dimensionen an
als weitere leichen entdeckt werden an
betten gefesselt und eingemauert in
diesem kargen schreib studio entwickelt
sein und bettgeschichten und den
charakter seines protagonisten die
meisten menschen finden meinen beruf
vermutlich seltsam gehört dazu mag aber
ich verbringe ebenso viel zeit mit den
toten wie mit den lebenden und
untersuche zerfall und auflösung um
menschliche überreste zu identifizieren
und zu verstehen was sie in diesem
zustand gebracht haben könnte das ist
eine oft ist hier aber wichtige
tätigkeit david hunter ist ein
wissenschafter und die geschichte ist
eine erzählung mit allen details aus
seiner perspektive
obwohl die meisten menschen das grausig
und abstoßend finden kann er mit einem
anderen blick darauf schauen und ich
denke deshalb können die leser das im
selben geist betrachten wenn man so will
david hunter romane beginnen immer mit
anthropologischen betrachtungen die
meisten menschen glauben zu wissen wie
verwesung
sie denken der geruch wäre markant
unverwechselbare faulige gestank des
grabes sie irren sich der geruch von
verwesung kann alle möglichen noten
enthalten ist komplex ich wollte mal
wissenschaftler werden ursprünglich
dieses wissenschaftliche interesse hatte
ich schon immer und mit dem schreiben
habe ich einen weg gefunden ist
einzubringen
allerhand geschichten fußen auf
forensischen fakten so auch die
vorangegangene restle steht auf deutsch
toten
der menschliche körper selbst zu über 60
prozent aus wasser besteht ist nicht von
sich aus schwimmfähig er treibt nur so
lange an der wasseroberfläche die luft
in den lungen vorhanden ist
sobald sie den körper verlässt sinkt
langsam auf den grund ist das wasser
sehr kalt oder dann bleibt er dort und
durchläuft einen düsteren
auflösungsprozess er jahre andauern kann
wenn das wasser aber waren genug ist um
bakterien lebensraum zu bieten
dann verliest er in den eingeweihten
entstehen gase die den körper auftrieb
geben so dass er an die oberfläche
zurück kehrt
dann erheben sich ganz buchstäblich die
toten dieser akribischer realität sind
gefällt den lesern
es gibt etwas das mich überrascht und
erfreut
viele leute sagen mir dass sie die david
hunter serie müden obwohl sie
normalerweise keine krimis lesen
der general psychiatry in beckett
heimatstadt sheffield ein ort voller
symbolik und tabus diamondbacks blickt
hinter diese kulisse er entmystifiziert
das grauen des todes konsequent indem er
ihn im nüchternen licht der wissenschaft
beschreibt ermöglicht er dem leser eine
sachliche annäherung eine rationale
auseinandersetzung auch mit den eigenen
gefühlen von angst und ekel
in der gesellschaft in der ich
aufgewachsen bin wurde der tod nicht
hinterfragt jemand stark blieb ein
rätsel was danach geschah darum diese
neugier was mit deinem körper passiert
nach dem tod physisch aber auch
spirituell was mit der person geschieht
einmal entdeckte ich einen verwesenden
hasen voller maden gegen bewegt obwohl
er tot war
ich war damals noch sehr jung haben sie
schlimme träume manchmal nein meine
träume kann schon recht gruselig sein
aber nicht in dieser hinsicht keine
albträume von verwiesen den gleichen
oder ähnlichen wie wichtig schauplätze
sind und wie er auf die idee des
forensischen anthropologen gekommen ist
das will er uns bei einem ausflug
erläutern
doch zuerst zurück in die rechtsmedizin
martin ostermayer